non je voudrais saint denis allex d'un
ami et 10 heures je voudrais y est des
silences veut dire on peut dire quelque
chose
y aller si vous pouvez voudrais signaler
que sur ce plateau ce soir sont tenues
des invités qui ont chacun le droit
d'amener un invité qui se teignent est
assis dans le fond de la salle j'aurais
voulu que ces gens respectent un peu
l'émission autrement nous naviguerons
plus les gens que sur l'émission mais ça
ça m'est égal vous n'aurez ce métier pas
du moment vous vous taisez voilà alors
je voudrais quand même pas je savais que
madame molinier qui est venu là soir
elle va finir par le regretter
parce que non mais je vous comprends
bien mais pas de chance le rideau on n'a
rien dit c'est ce qu'on dit à chaque
émission alors si laure dufresnes voilà
c'est ce qu'on dit à chaque échange et
moi on pourrait peut-être dire des
choses concrètes des machines étudié la
situation dise parce que le fond du
poème dans le showbiz mal et on le sort
ce monsieur mais alors nous allons aider
je regrette que les que les invités mais
amener des élus
et je vais vous faire écouter une
chanson chef de l'état sur cette chanson
est une chanson de siècle voilà qu'on se
regarde est d'accord les cellules à
envoyer générique de fin et couper
l'image parce que c'est vraiment pas
plaisant
mettez le le générique de fin avec la
chanson de dia colombes
voilà mettez la chanson de biakolo nous
et il fait l'antenne ans qu'on plante
est née je m'excuse on peut les
téléspectateurs toi qui m'as
heureux temps
de blanchot
bonsoir
merci
bonsoir merci de merci de cet accueil
chaleureux et pardon pour cette semaine
de retard c'est la première de champs
elysées nous nous retrouverons tous les
samedis à 20h30 sur antenne 2 pendant 70
minutes environ divertissante après une
semaine difficile vous méritez aussi de
vous divertir cette émission sa modeste
ambition est de vous faire oublier vos
soucis en vous faisant découvrir des
visages nouveaux qui seront associés à
des locomotives je voudrais remercier
tous ceux qui sont venus assister à
notre émission dans les plus beaux
jardins du monde c'est un journaliste
qui l'a écrit ce matin les jardins des
champs elysées là où marcel proust en
1880 est menée à jouer au cerceau et cet
espace c'est très célèbre dans le monde
entier déjà l'espace cardin c'est là où
nous nous retrouverons les missions et
public
il n'y a pas beaucoup de place aux pas
nous en vouloir c'est pas baltard
mais si vous êtes patient quand
l'émission et f de maver si vous nous
écrivez dès maintenant j'espère que vous
recevrez vos places je remercie la
presse de province la presse parisienne
qui est là je le ferai plus longuement
tout à l'heure et j'aimerais pour
commencer que vos applaudissements
aillent à ceux qui ont beaucoup
travaillé avec nous ils sont un petit
peu tremblant ce soir car transformer un
petit théâtre en studio de télévision
savait pas évident ce sont tous les
techniciens de la sfp
merci je vais pas tous les citer mais je
vais citer le réalisateur jacques brialy
je vais citer francis remballe
décorateur charlie garraud dalta
monsieur connaissait pas c'est lui qui a
équipé tous avec la lumière
il ya notre ami martial tuerie qui est
le directeur de la photo il a un rôle
capital à jouer ce soir et je voudrais
bien sûr remercié accueillir dans cette
salle nous patrons notre président
directeur général pierre des groupes est
représentée par joseph pasteur est
également présente monsieur jacques
nakache il faut toujours applaudir les
patrons et d'une émission
bien vous avez compris ce n'est pas très
compliqué il suffit de suivre les
consignes que nous vous donnons par le
moyen de la télévision maintenant après
toutes ces explications une
démonstration
le petit film que vous allez voir
apparaître sur cet écran que vous n'avez
pas chez vous mais que j'ai chez moi là
juste devant les yeux là va me dire ce
qu'il faut faire j'ai déjà mes rondes et
coupé voyez il ya ici une petite caisse
qui doit alemao aux chalets vous voyez
mais comment faire il n'ya pas
d'escalier n'y a pas de treuil à rien
voilà le la caisse et là-haut et le
chalet
comment faire que dois-je faire le film
vannes le 10ème tous les petits besoins
vont le dire j'attends tout simplement
certainement des pointillés
voilà les pointillés auger pas le rond
de la bonne taille mon dieu
est-ce que ça va marcher c'est une façon
savoir je le mets là suivant les
pointillés
on va pas donner le beau rôle je les nie
vous êtes en chercher le nul auront de
bonnes valeurs
j'ai collé montrond je découvre avec
vous là un voile à regarder c'est un
ballon regardez la caisse en vol et
grâce au ballon que vous avez misé 120
écrans
le miracle
ça c'est super
voyez c'est facile et poussée par le
vent le petit ballon va déposer
doucement la caisse sur le chalet si
merveilleux ça vous riez je peux le
faire dont vous pouvez le faire
c'est tellement simple alors tout au
long de l'été nous vous expliquerons
comment marche ce téléc tac
voyez les petits pointier sont revenus
ça veut dire qu'il faut que j'enlève la
feuille de plastique et l'image va
redevenir normale telle qu'elle doit
être
enfin bref tout l'été voilà l'image
finale tout l'été vous allez apprendre à
faire fonctionner le télé taktika et
nous jouerons ensemble
au mois sept ans
alors le pdt les mecs c'est une
tradition l'habitude ah oui ah bah là là
je sens que ça va
alors avant avant moi je veux bien mais
c'est dangereux quand même avant d'aller
au fond des choses
j'aimerais que vous me donniez un petit
peu vos projets qu'est ce qui va se
passer là maintenant tout de suite je
sors donc mon livre qui s'appelle sans
famille ses besoins avant le 15 novembre
je prépare l'olympia du à partir du 7
janvier je serai donc à l'olympia les
locations sont illégales sont ouvertes
c'est un très beau publicitaire il est
très très bon je voulais ça puisque
c'est là bas c'est le jingle pelé mec
qui veut qu'on a vu leur plaie mexes et
je vous laisse je me suis dit maintenant
moi je reviens cela dit ça me dérange
pas tu vois vraiment pas ce que je me
déshabille à la chaîne des années
pensez vous qu'il aurait voulu raconter
là
oui
et je prends racine
toi tu as
qui dit
à toi
comment
tu es
non non non non non non
à
là on va on arrête parce que ça va être
l'enfer on va je ne veux pas qu'on voit
qu'on aille jusqu'au bout des choses en
revanche on va voir l'art nathan à
scopitone lançait tout dit au clip
johnny hallyday c'est des scopitones
sept ont conduit la planète
c'est à vous je vous rappelle pas le
visage pâle et cheveux surtout pas trop
parce que la peau vous donne une
indication
absolument pas
ravissante
lehmann était né sait pas elle croit
qu'on va passer la seconde convient si
l'on s'en prend le dessus à la bonne
hauteur mais il faut bien vérifier quand
même tous attention troisième candidate
vous êtes juste devant est juste à la
bonne hauteur justement il va falloir
prendre une décision amène maintenant tu
peux plus vous laisser le choix à j ai
vu c'est elle c'est elle vit sur un game
gecina
je sais pas je crains que ça soit perdu
qu'est ce qui vous a trompé c'est
peut-être l'ambiance